if you want to begin to really enjoy a
happy successful healthy life you've got
to be willing to go against the tide
you've got to be willing to harness your
will
[Music]
and say in spite of this
I'm in control here
I'm not going to let this get me down
I'm not going to let this destroy me
it doesn't matter about what happens to
you what matters is what are you going
to do about it what are you going to do
now Les
how long are you going to tell everybody
at the bus stop and anybody who would
stand and listen to you
and you're going to repeat the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over again how many times do we have
to hear that don't go around telling
people what your story is everybody has
a story eighty percent don't care and 20
glad it's you you can permit it to let
you let it hold you down or you can
decide I'm not going to let that happen
to me I'm bigger than this
yes make a declaration to yourself
declare all-out war that you're going to
get out of this rug
I don't care how good you ought to care
how talented you are I don't care how
much you work on yourself there are some
times when things aren't going to go
right
they just are not going to go right
there are times when anything that can
happen will happen the challenges of
life
how do we get stuck your mind is is you
know when you're going to a service
station to get gas you don't go in there
and just start pumping when you push the
lever up it clears the previous bill
by the same token if you want to begin
to move you've got to clear your mind of
all the unnecessary luggage and baggage
that's weighing us down
I couldn't move I couldn't think about
what am I going to do you're going to
have people to do things to you things
are going to happen to you and the most
important thing to do is to harness your
will and let it go and move so you can
grow so you can get on with your life
sometimes your life will be in a slump
just like sports
some of the best Shooters can't hit
baskets different times in games they
get in a slump do they sit on the
sideline and say you know I just didn't
hit a basket today no they continue to
execute I suggest to you that if you are
facing a challenge don't stop
stay busy work your plan continue to do
those things that you know that work for
you after you have evaluated yourself
from the situation continue to move stay
busy stay busy stay busy you want a free
throw line get your team's down by one
you get to shoot two free throws at zero
time on the clock game seven of the NBA
final like we all dream of that but
didn't we get in real life we want to be
punks we get in real life we solve it's
like yo let the gas go up I'm gonna make
more money let the inflation go up game
seven man like this game seven in London
let's go if it was easy everybody would
do it I don't even want it to be easy
everybody would get a PhD if it was easy
to get a PhD then it wouldn't be
valuable so I tell people like look look
at the tragedies and say yo you thought
well enough for me to come at me
this is what I do cut all the lights off
if you want to you're not going to stop
me because you got all the lights this
is where I thrive and I'm saying if
you're a real human
because we are a little different than
some of the other things that were
created we have a whale there's some
things that we have I'm like active made
it instead of crying and quitting and
giving up again we're going to go
through pain prepare yourself in advance
for these situations so that when they
come you have a better chance of
controlling those situations and not
letting those situations control you 50
Now 60 maybe 80 maybe 90 of my life is
going already I don't have in time Tom
is not waiting for me Tom is not my
friend and I'm not talking about your
type of time I'm talking about t i m e
time don't like nobody
Tom hate all of us time is trying to
stay away from us
you think I'ma waste the rest of the
time that I got to be operating out here
crying and complaining blaming somebody
no so what I'm complaining about but the
time you have children by the time you
have uh made a way for your children by
the time you've paid for your home
you're pushing 60 years old
so life is real short
so yeah while you're traveling out of
all you're sleeping out of all your
school at a ball entertainment you've
probably been half your life doing
nothing so what am I I'm 35 years old 30
more years I'll be 65. we don't have no
more influence we can't do nothing much
at 65 so we don't have it about 80 years
on Earth this is a test to see where
will we spend our life in heaven hell
this is not the life now your real self
is inside you your body gets old your
hair is leaving you your bodies get
tired but your soul and your spirit
never die that's gonna live forever so
your body is just housing your soul and
spirit so God is testing us on how we
treat each other how we live you know
how much time and energy people spend
the average person I'm just doing the
ballpark figure they spend years and
years maybe a decade complaining
bitching and whining and still nothing
change I could be using that time to
change my life I could be inducing that
time to embrace the reality of life and
the reality of the that I've done
to put my so I paid for my ticket I got
on the train it was many stops that came
I didn't get off at them stops I went to
the final destination of the kid that I
was living in I went through the process
of that dump kit I grew up I evolved
from that now it's time to live now it's
time to just be out here on a journey
through life experiencing new things new
ideas exposure and that's what I
realized I wasn't a lot of us don't
expose ourselves to new things new ideas
we're not open open to different open to
change everything that I want to do is
for me that's why it's here
everything that you want to do you can
do that's why it's here it is about are
you willing to put the work everything
is out here for everybody that's why
it's out here once you able to breathe
you got all the tools you need please
don't put a limit on what you can do
when you haven't even tried to do what
you're capable of doing see somebody
along the way told you you were supposed
to retire and it's 65 you're supposed to
get a check and we like idiots decided
that we should cash in our lives at
those particular years
that's what made that decision and guess
what when you think like that guess what
you dress like you oh you walk like you
oh you talk like you retired
because somebody told you at this age
you supposed to throw in the towel
no if you're willing to pursue your
dream then your goals change and your in
your level of sacrifice change was I
afraid yes was I certain there was
certainty in what I was doing though but
also in the back of my mind I'm gonna
tell you I cheated a little bit I said I
could always go back to happy yeah I
cheated myself and then finally after a
year I wouldn't stop cheating yourself
why was it cheating yourself because
when you want to do something in your
life you don't put options out there you
don't put a b plan well you don't know
where you're going in life do not look
four years down the line do not look two
years all year you look next week next
month you keep your goals short and that
way as you accomplish those goals then
you can start piling up little trophies
a little moments to know that you
actually accomplishing something you
actually climbing the steps to success
and so I always tell people shortening
your goals shorten your window and
that's how you find your voice most
people are standing jobs or working
things or even marriages or
relationships because they fear change
can I do better can I get a better
opportunity will somebody hire me will
somebody date me or somebody married
would somebody want my kids that I have
that's a fear and people don't want to
make change so I don't just take it from
just an entrepreneurial standpoint I
take that conversation to the social
behavior of people where they don't want
to make adjustments because they've
already told themselves they can't do it
and when you make adjustments when you
when you stop yourself first really sad
because let somebody else tell you what
you cannot do but in the process of that
prepare for success in other words are
you willing to put time in your next
move and a lot of people a lot of people
say things like I'm not a morning person
I don't really know what that means I
really don't I have 24 hours in the day
I try to take advantage of every hour
and I have certain rules that I
initially tell people on a regular basis
if you want to start living a successful
life start locking into a consistent
time that you should get up every day
don't let it deviate don't if you say
get up at eight o'clock don't don't
don't hit the snooze and get up at 8 30.
I get up at 4 30. that's just my time
I'm not a happy guy getting up but
that's a goal I said and I'ma just tell
you this honestly if you're about to
make a change in your life and you feel
uncomfortable that's the best feeling
you can have because For the first time
in your life you're making a decision
that's going to be best for you and not
what somebody told you to do and that's
when all bets are off man because you're
about to enter some some uncharted
waters that's going to force you to
challenge yourself to be perfect in so
many ways then and shooting for
Perfection is all good you don't shoot
for average because you're not gonna hit
it you're not going to hit all of that
if you shoot for Perfection and you hit
good or great you winning they think
it's a permanent fix
they think it's something that are
constant
they think that maybe once I get it I'm
gonna hold on to it nothing is permanent
nothing is permanent and a lot of times
you have to learn to perform without
motivation
you get to learn perform without purpose
you have to learn to perform a lot of
different things and that's what people
think they think I need to have this
motivation to work out to study to be
better so if they don't have it they
just don't do it and that's where you
fail
you have to learn to train your mind
well beyond motivation if you have
motivation that's great that's some can
lean to the fire all it takes is a
little bit and Sparky you can burn the
whole Force up
but
motivation you get to learn to exist
without it you have to be your best self
and your least motivated
and that's the tricky part about all
that
motivation is just a word you have to
have these different things in your mind
on where you want to go and know that
motivation is not going to get me there
because I'm not going to always be
motivated I don't really like those
words
self-help or self-management or
self-improvement
I don't really like what those words
have come to mean these days because
there's a lot of people out there that
are constantly trying to improve
themselves
by looking for the one change the one
change right the one change in their
life that's gonna make their dreams come
true now
I'm no guru and I definitely don't claim
to be I'm just a man but I will tell you
this it isn't one thing
and it isn't ten things and it isn't a
hundred things it isn't a quick path and
there are no shortcuts
meditation won't get you there and
neither will a miracle drug or an
organic supplement or some SuperFood
getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or a one change that you need to make
getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign it's a daily a weekly it's an
hourly fight
an incessant fight that doesn't stop
against weakness and against Temptation
and against laziness it's a campaign of
discipline a campaign of hard work and
dedication it's waking up early and
going to bed late and grinding out every
second in between
every single day
so you want to get better
you want to self-improve stop looking
for a shortcut and go find your alarm
clock find your discipline and find your
guts and your passion and your drive and
find it you will and then you will find
your freedom
find somebody that you can help so you
can forget about you for a moment see
sometimes the best thing to do is to be
sometimes you have to just back up and
go within yourself a bow and arrow you
you can't take a boat and just push it
out of there you just can't push the
arrow out you have to pull it back
and then release it
sometimes you'll have to back up and go
within and pray and meditate and
recharge your batteries go away clear
your head and then come back and look at
it from a different vantage point
don't operate while you're under the
spell or the effect of what's going on
next thing is that you've got to
activate the Thinker in you
don't allow your emotions to control you
we are emotional but you want to begin
to discipline your emotion
if you don't discipline and contain your
emotions they will use you
your mind goes on automatic just like a
god you know
you know weeds don't have to have any
encouragement to grow
you don't have to water them they don't
have to get Sunshine they don't have to
have fertile ground they will grow
through the cracks of a sidewalk
am I right
but if you want to grow orchids or roses
or any kind of exotic flowers there are
special processes and procedures you
must go through
well by the same token you don't have to
force yourself or motivate yourself to
think negatively
to be depressed to hate somebody to want
revenge you want to get back at somebody
to beat yourself up over the head to
feel loaded with guilt you don't have to
make any effort to do that your mind is
on automatic it will do that by itself
but if you want to begin to move into
your own personal greatness if you want
to begin to really enjoy a happy
successful healthy life you've got to be
willing to go against the tide you've
got to be willing to harness your will
and say in spite of this
I'm in control here
I'm not going to let this get me down
I'm not going to let this destroy me
I'm coming back
and I'll be stronger and better because
of it you have got to make a declaration
this is what you stand for you're
standing up for your dreams you're
standing up for peace of mind you're
standing up for health
you want it
and you're going to go all out to have
it
it's not going to be easy when you want
to change it's not easy if it were in
fact easy everybody to do it but if
you're serious you'll go all out